There's the group at the center of major
conspiracy theories have been accused
of pulling the strings of major
governments around the world for inserting
symbols into such prominent places.
As the US dollar bill and conspiracy
theorists have claims that everyone from
the Beatles to Tom Brady to Kanye West
are more recent members of the centuries
old society.
There's no doubt the Illuminati have
impacted welder fast even if just by being
at the center of conspiracy theories.
But where did this group get it start?
Well,
let's take a look at the man
behind the secret society.
Johann Adam.
Why stopped
Johann Adam Weishaupt,
who was born into an academic
household in Bavaria.
He came into the world
on February the sixth,
17,
48 is the son of a law professor.
When she was only five years old,
his father passed away,
leaving him to be raised
by his grandfather.
Also a law professor,
Weiss helps grandfather kept caps,
the Boeing engaged in
scholastic activities.
His grandfather was a proponent of the
enlightenment movements and the thoughts
and philosophies promoted
by enlightenment thinkers,
came to greatly influence Weiss hops
during the 17th and 18th century.
Enlightenment movements.
Intellectuals emphasized the importance
of reason and individualism over
tradition.
You might also hear the enlightenment
referred to as the age of reason among the
movements most famous thinkers with
John Locke and Isaac Newton when he was
seven years old.
Ice Helps Education expanded
beyond his grandfather's teaching.
The family was Catholic and why sap
to began attending a jesuit school.
He was a voracious reader and
by the time he was 20 years old,
he has and his doctorate in law.
He began teaching law bars.
Within a year he became the beneficiary
of the dissolution of the very religious
order that had educated him.
Political maneuvering coupled
with cultural changes made.
The jesuits are a threat to the
power of some European leaders,
at least in their eyes.
The order was suppressed in several
countries and even the pope issued a brief
suppressing the jesuits because of
the order suppression in Seventeen,
73 wise helped was able to move from being
a professor of secular law to being a
professor of Canon law at the University
of English start before the suppression
only jesuits towards Canon Law now waste,
which could be a professor,
but he nonetheless found himself as
the only non clergy member serving.
As such,
although the order has been suppressed,
they still wielded considerable power
at the university and Weiss hubs and his
enlightenment influenced ideas well.
We hit some roadblocks as a result,
helped grew to dislike clerics.
He was frustrated and he wanted a way
to spread the words of the enlightenment
without being stonewalled by the chair.
Ouch.
So he decided to start his own society
about what was the goal of this society.
This is the great object held down by
this association as the means of attaining
it is illumination enlightening the
understanding by the son of reason which
will dispel the clowns of superstition
and prejudice initially why sobs didn't
want to start his own secret society
he had wanted to join the free masons,
is a group that he thought would line up
nicely with his passion for reason over
religion,
but ultimately he decided that the free
masons weren't exactly what he wanted
and so he took the leap and
started his own society.
He didn't look to the freemasons for
inspiration in rituals and organizational
structure,
though overtime,
especially after I stopped,
ended up joining the freemasons.
The two groups became more
linked in the minds of many,
especially conspiracy
theorists to start a society.
Why Sampson began reaching
out to like minded men.
He had befriended at university,
but they had to be young men.
Anyone over 30 was just too unlikely to
be influenced by new ideas and I tapped.
He wanted the men who joined to be true
believers in the enlightenment ready to
start spreading the ideals of reason
and spreading them as high up as they
could.
The group of men first match in May of 17,
76,
only five of them arrived in the forest
that first night carrying torches and
ready to embark on their quest to
spread their ideas to the world to be
initiated into the Illuminati.
Why Sally wanted his members to
experience being reborn this way,
they would be leaving behind their lives
before joining the Illuminati and to be
able to fully immerse themselves in their
commitment to the new secret society.
The initiation rights included sacrifices
and mystical elements who did men
unknown identities in darkened
rooms are hallmarks of such rights.
Games have been made that the
Illuminati initiation rights.
I've taken the sacrifice element
to its most extreme stage,
the sacrificing of an actual human
being to be initiated and reborn.
The idea is that the new member would
have to experience death and be reborn and
actually killing someone would give
them an insight into the experience of
death,
but the initiation rite is also sent to
have given many members the experience
of death and rebirth through
the killing of an animal.
The illuminati would put an
animal on top of the new member,
kill the animal and just let it bleed to
death on top of the new member soaking
in the animal's bloods,
encouraged rebirth and
the understanding of life,
death and knowledge overall.
Why Sally did not want the Illuminati
to remain just a small academic society
that operated in an echo chamber,
though he wanted it to reach the highest
echelons of society with members both
influencing political leaders and even
the coming political leaders themselves,
but he also didn't want the
society to grow full of men.
He couldn't trust until you weren't
truly dedicated to the course.
So the men that mets that first night,
we'd have to be agreed to by the five
members present at night as well as prove
themselves to be from families
of high standing and wealth.
The latter two requirements
would help with myself,
skull to get his ideas moving up the
societal ladder and into the minds of
intellectual families and society.
Now,
the order's famous name.
It didn't to ice out right
away the first name boy,
his secretive group was the perfect lists,
a name that they actually
stuck with for two years.
The idea that a man is perfectible
was part of the group's ideals.
Even American founding father Thomas
Jefferson appreciated this trait of ice
arts and design ideas,
stating why Sam's seems to be
an enthusiastic philanthropist.
He is among those,
as you know,
the excellent Richard price and priestly
also are who believe in the indefinite
perfectibility of man.
He thinks he may in time be rendered so
perfect that he will be able to govern
itself in every circumstance,
so as to engine none to do well,
the goody can to leave.
Government had no occasion to exercise
their powers over him and of course to
render political government useless
before the name Illuminati was officially
adopted.
Why?
Sam's also thought about naming the
group the be order that's in the Nazi was
ultimately decided upon.
And why Sam's took the
owl as the group symbol.
So now you might be wondering,
well,
why did you choose now?
What exactly is the
significance of this bird?
Now Minerva,
the goddess of wisdom was
accompanied by an owl.
The Owl was away for ways,
helped to indicate the intellectual
basis for the secret society while still
keeping its symbolism just to be coded.
The new name was a callback to the
occult beliefs within the Spanish culture
during medieval times,
alchemists and magicians were believed
to be imbued with a light that signified
the presence of a higher power
within within the society.
The members took nicknames.
Why?
Subs as the head of the
order was spartacus,
while other adopted names
from members included,
a Jackson Tiberius in 17,
77.
Why's helped found a new
avenue for recruiting.
He was accepted into a free masons group
in Germany and use their society as a
place to find well connected society.
Men who were already acquainted with
and interested in secret societies.
The men who were welcomed
in were told the following.
Should you see might power
false honor excess seek vote.
We would work for you to provide
your temporal advantages.
We will bring you as close to the throne
as you wish and then turn you over to
the consequences of your folly,
but our inner sanctuary
remains closed to such,
which who do you want to learn?
Wisdom wants to learn to
make mankind's more clever,
better free and happy,
then be thrice welcomed by us.
The men who joined new found order found
themselves a part of a group that was
split into distinct levels as much as
waste helped refine the principles of
rationalism and individualism related
to the enlightenment movements,
the men who were a part of his fault,
where restrictors in their knowledge
about what was going on within their own
organization.
The illuminati had a hierarchy within
the structure and the members at the
bottom reported to those.
At the top there were three ranks of men,
novice minerval and illuminated minerval
eliminate them interval where at the
top of the Illuminati is pecking order
than I am inspired by the Roman goddess
of wisdom.
They spied on each other
and on the political and
economic goings on in society.
Bringing news back to the order and to
helping the Illuminati move forward and
its goals of influencing
the top tiers of society.
Do you realize sufficiently what it means
to rule to rule in a secret society,
not only over the lesser or
more importance of the populace,
but over the best of men
over men of all ranks,
nations and religions to rule without
external force to unite them in
dishonorably to breathe one
spirit and soul into them.
Men distributed over all parts
of the world in his first year,
so they'll even ask.
It didn't grow by leaps and bounds.
Initially,
they found only a few dozen
interested in qualified men to join.
They know that it's just 60 by 78 80,
but that year,
why stopped added amendment to the
Illuminati who proved himself to be
especially helpful in gaining new members
and he also attracted a new level of
respect for the secret
society and this new member.
He came from.
Why Sampson recruiting
grounds in the freemasons,
baron adult Conega had been
a member of the freemasons,
but he had risen as far as he
could go within their ranks.
So when he heard of y soft
and his new smaller group,
he saw an opportunity to have real
sway over what was going on in the
organization.
He also likes the Illuminati
is relationship with
mysticism and forming the
order why Sam's had relied
in part on mystic texts.
He read the mysteries of the seven sages
of Memphis and the Kabbalah and the two
tanks.
It's made an impact on how he
viewed the world around him.
Baron Canoga was also a students of
such ideas and liked that why salvage
brought their influence
into the Illuminati when
he joined gonna get eagerly
read the texts required of new members,
most consistent of works that were banned
in the conservative Catholic Bavaria.
In fact,
contigo read the text so quickly
that we had to stall for time.
He didn't want can I get to reach the
illuminated minerva level so quickly?
So he put off Grenada.
Well,
he tried to come up with new ideas
for readings and required actions,
but kinda figured out that y sub two is
trying to delay his achievements of the
highest level when he
brought this up to wise,
help wise,
helped,
was willing to listen.
It was also willing to
listen to Canadians.
New ideas for the order for one Canadian
said the order needed a rearrangement
of its hierarchy.
He suggested bringing in new levels
under the existing three levels.
The end result of this was 13 ranks of
Illuminati members each subdivided within
the original three levels.
The three new overarching levels
have the names of the nursery,
the messianic grades,
and the mysteries can also
used his influence to change.
Why?
How strong messaging about
the church and about religion.
He realized that such a strong stance
might be hampering the group's ability to
grow and recruit new and powerful members
after the church wielded much power in
Bavaria in the 18th century,
and even the promise that our society
with secrets might not be strong enough
assurance for men from powerful
families to risk joining.
Why subs listens to you.
Can you get.
And the Illuminati,
they benefited from an
organization of just 60.
They grew to 200 by 17,
82,
then the group group to
3000 members by 1784.
The illuminati or Dorsey spread beyond
varia membership now included Hungary,
Poland,
and Italy.
But having that many members spread
throughout a number of countries made it
harder and harder to keep things quiet,
and if they're very purpose was to
infiltrate and influence political thought
and actions,
then of course the upper echelons of
society would start to notice them.
In 1794,
that group became a problem.
Then members of the Illuminati were
sending correspondence back and forth and
the governments have their eye out for
his writings with internal Illuminati
ideas and policies were
intercepted in Bavaria.
It's also been thought that this
interception was set up by this point wise
helped handsome,
disgruntled members within his ranks.
When we first started the organization,
he told some members that
would be a supernatural
communication if they achieved
the highest level within the society,
but plenty of people who
had achieved this by 17,
84 and there was no supernatural
communication to be hat
baron can Nigga and why
Sam's.
They also had a major disagreements.
They didn't have the same idea about
some of the societies rituals and their
arguments culminated in Canoga
leaving the secret society.
The same year he left the Illuminati.
The Bavarian government
banned all secret societies.
That was in 1784,
which was the same year that
the membership had exploded.
By the next year.
The Bavarian government
took it a step further.
They banned the Illuminati specifically
as part of the Illuminati banishment.
The government began reading.
The documents have known Illuminati
documents started to be published,
and it's this secret
society and its membership.
It wasn't so secret anymore.
Public officials became known as members
putting that livelihoods and societal
rankings on the line.
The illuminati simply couldn't
function with its membership.
Being known throughout all of this society
building and government influencing
why sapped had still been working as a
professor at the University of English
stocks,
but when the government
banned the Illuminati,
he was forced to flee his home
and leave behind his job wise,
it wasn't kind to the governments,
to governments of any
sorts of not just Bavaria,
so it is not surprising that they
were not pleased with his writings.
So just how strongly did he
feel about the governments?
Well,
take this quote,
when man lives under government,
he has fallen,
is worth is gone and his nature tarnished
when the illuminati were bands from
Bavaria.
Why Sandra was forced to fleet
to go to another part of Germany.
That waste helped,
was protected by a sympathetic duke.
Duke Ernest not only provided
political protection for Weiss ops,
but he also gave him a pension that's
allowed him to live without working.
Even though the Illuminati had been
disbanded in various [inaudible],
kept pushing the ideas that had led him
to start the secret society in the first
place.
He began rising ultimately publishing
for books about the history of the
Illuminati and defending.
It's existence.
The books were intended both to defend
himself and to perhaps encourage new
growth for the Illuminati
and the province of Gota.
There's one way helped
passed away in 1830.
The illuminati had all but
disappeared from the world.
It's not easy to operate
even as a secret society.
When major world powers,
they simply want you gone.
While the Illuminati may have disappeared,
at least in membership in Europe.
The group by no means disappeared from
the world's imagination and conversations
based on today's conspiracy theories
and the prevalence of the Illuminati and
pop culture.
It can be argued that why south succeeded
in creating a secret society that had
an influence on the world.
Dan Brown's massively popular novels
feature the Illuminati in angels and
demons.
Brown pits the Illuminati against the
Catholic church in a modern setting.
Throughout the book,
they use churches and
artwork to commit atrocities,
relying heavily on
coded symbolism benders.
The illuminati trilogy books that claim
George Washington was actually replaced
by a member of the Illuminati.
They claim that this imposter
actually ran the United States.
People even suggest that the ion,
the American $1 bill is an indication
of Illuminati interference and American
governments why stops and the Illuminati
are also used in video games and comic
books and even rap songs.
There are regular feature on history
channel shows and mysterious shows about
conspiracies from all around the world.
When major events happen,
think that JFK assassination
and nine slash 11,
the Illuminati name still gets tossed
around as a possible course and there's
even a theory that the
modern day Illuminati and now
headquartered in Bavaria or
where it was founded,
but right in the heart
of the United States.
I was in Washington DC,
not in New York,
not in Los Angeles,
but in Denver,
hidden beneath the airport
and the Colorado city is
said to be the headquarters
for the modern day incarnation of the
most powerful secret society in the world.
Everything from the airports,
runway design to its underground tunnels
have been pointed to as evidence for
why it's a perfect site for
the societies operation.
It seems that 250 years after we first
launched his idea for a secret society is
influenced,
is still felt from pop culture
to events of historic magnitude.
The illuminati is still a factor,
at least in terms of people
bringing up their name.
Now,
it might not be exactly what he
was planning or maybe it was,
do we really know how a secret
society operates and has influence,
I mean by south did plan for
the Illuminati to operate
in the backgrounds after
all,
so I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put our brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive over
there on the right and as always,
thank you for watching.